with more than 14 minutes of brand new
hogwarts legacy gameplay footage it's no
surprise that eagle-eyed fans are
already finding a ridiculous amount of
hidden details easter eggs and secrets
that are sure to please long-time harry
potter fans so in today's video we're
going to take a detailed look at the new
trailer to talk about 55 secrets you may
have missed first up at the 38 second
mark the main character approaches
hogwarts under darkness if you look
through this darkness just behind the
character you'll see a familiar sight
for harry potter fans and what is
undoubtedly the quidditch pitch
quidditch still hasn't been officially
confirmed to be in the game or at least
playable in the game a little bit
further in at the 51 second mark an
armored troll demolishes this building
and charges the player note the red eyes
which are almost certainly linked to the
corruption mentioned later on in the
trailer at 107 you'll get this amazing
wide shot of hogwarts where you can make
out a number of familiar locations such
as the owlery herbology greenhouses and
plenty more then at 114 you'll step
inside hogwarts and get a glimpse of an
older version of the school crests
featuring the four houses as well as
house specific banners for this shot at
118 of the trailer professor figg and
our character are standing before some
sort of portal that's clearly showing
gringotts on the other side perhaps this
is some sort of fast travel system since
our character can't apparate yet just a
few frames later the same duo find
themselves in an even larger room with a
series of similar looking portals the
flooring in this room also catches the
eye here and almost appears to be a map
of surrounding terrain or perhaps this
location is somewhere deep underwater at
127 we get our first glimpse of the
goblin rand rock and you'll notice he
has the r adorning his belt here he also
has a goblin to his right in some sort
of law enforcement uniform perhaps a
security officer at gringotts in this
scene here we move back into the great
hall which contains a number of features
relating back to the four houses such as
the lion here and eagle here at 146 you
get a close-up shot of the stained glass
window which also features the house
mascots as well as the winged boars of
hogwarts you can also make out some text
here that appears to be at least
inspired by latin the first word means
true the second means learn the third
means truthful and the fourth means
magic so safe to say it's saying
something about learning true magic the
various circles here below would appear
to show different phases of the moon as
our character wakes up in the gryffindor
common room you'll catch sight of a
moving portrait in the background this
portrait turns out to be the first of
many as numerous portraits throughout
the castle seem to have a life of their
own in the very brief shot of the
hufflepuff common room we see quite a
few plants scattered throughout perhaps
this one here is a memberless
mimbletonia here we find two characters
in a classroom with a number of spells
printed on the boards behind them some
of which have yet to be confirmed as
usable in the game at 2 25 as we move
into the charms classroom you'll catch
sight of a diagram here showing a
mountain troll a few seconds later we
get a wider shot which reveals even more
spells in the background and let's talk
about this professor for just a moment
if you take a closer look at the
pendants he's wearing here they appear
to be snakes on both sides could it be
that our charms professor is the head of
slytherin house as our character heads
out into the courtyard you'll see that
the students are dressed in a variety of
different clothing types there are also
multiple slytherins in the shot that
appear to be wearing quidditch robes and
equipment at 3 23 our character makes
their way down the hall toward a
portrait in what almost has to be the
fat lady in her position guarding the
entrance to gryffindor tower later at 3
48 we're treated to a quick look at the
fifth floor prefix bathroom which
appears to be designed nearly exactly as
described in the books i mean look at
this it features a number of colored
water taps and even the diving board
guys they put the diving board in here
the students are in what is undoubtedly
the history of magic classroom and it
looks like professor bins was boring
students even back in the late 1800s
also if you look in the background here
on the window you'll clearly see the
name of merlin and that's not the only
mention of merlin in this trailer in
this sequence here our character casts
accio to retrieve a floating book
perhaps this is a hint we'll once again
be finding lost items for other students
in a nod to the original harry potter
video games here as our character
catches up on the magic they've missed
out on learning you'll spot the game
keeper's hud in the background and here
around 4 24 most people are talking
about this shot which shows someone
flying on a broom in a quidditch uniform
with the quidditch pitch in the
background but if you pull back just a
few frames earlier notice the creature
on the ground here it's certainly a
winged creature but at least from this
angle it doesn't appear to be a
hippogriff perhaps it's a thestral or
maybe even a young dragon dare i say the
trailer is packed full of magical
creatures including the floopers here in
this shot at 4 54 we get a nice close-up
view of the daily prophet which shows a
date of september 1st 1890. this gives
us a much more specific time frame than
the broad late 1800s avalanche has
referred to so far there are two
specific notes about this date that i
find interesting first of all
considering it's september 1st that
would be the start of a new term at
hogwarts perhaps this moment is when our
character is actually flying to hogwarts
for the first time and yet they
certainly don't appear to be taking the
hogwarts express y remains to be seen
the 1890 date also means we'd be
starting our hogwarts journey two years
before albus dumbledore arrives at the
school should the player character
created in hogwarts legacy c their
seventh year either in this game or
possibly a sequel then that same year is
when we should see a young albus
dumbledore arrive at hogwarts for the
first time we also get a look at ran
rock's power and he's clearly capable of
some strong magic as he blocks the
incoming spell from fig and fires back
in retaliation and of course he does all
of this without a wand i mentioned the
troll with red eyes earlier and here you
can also see that these goblins have the
same red eyes and this scene plays just
as the narrator describes creatures
being corrupted by some unknown magical
force at 6 15 we see two wands colliding
in an effect that looks practically
identical to harry and voldemort's stool
in harry potter and the goblet of fire
when priory and cantatum occurs it's
worth noting those who worked on the
films took a bit of creative liberty
with this visual effect considering it
would appear in other duels throughout
the rest of the series even among
wizards whose wands didn't share cores
in this shot we see a banner showing
some sort of winged creature perhaps a
phoenix and later at 807 there's this
adorable demiguise statue here we get a
great look at the main menu of the game
notice the character inventory talents
collections challenges map outpost quest
and settings tabs across the top the
cards in the middle also confirm will be
upgrading core abilities stealth
abilities room of requirement and two
others on the left that they don't hover
over in the trailer the one on the far
left is almost certainly spells but what
about the red one here i'm just guessing
here but perhaps these are offensive
spells whereas the blue on the left are
more for navigating the world it appears
our character will learn revelio at some
point notice how after they cast this
spell we can instantly see hidden
objects highlighted in yellow through
the walls at 8 22 we get a quick look at
some stealth gameplay after the
character casts a disillusionment charm
to sneak up on the unsuspecting wizard
walking through the room here the same
room is also home to multiple loot
chests which you can see here and here
again staying in this same room we can
make out yet another banner on the wall
this one appears to be of a centaur
using a bow here we get a nice look at
the gear upgrade menu which includes a
section for traits upgrades and
appearance on the right side of this
shot you'll find an eerie sight of house
elf heads mounted to the wall perhaps
this is a nod to house elves hanging in
number 12 grimald place back in the
original series and in this scene we
spot what appears to be even more
students in quidditch robes and
quidditch gear who knows maybe the
characters here are all heading down to
watch a match between ravenclaw and
slytherin throughout the trailer you may
also notice these little green flames
that appear around hogwarts it's unknown
what they are at this time but my guess
is there's some kind of landmark that
may even serve as a fast travel point or
maybe even a save point then again most
games these days allow you to save
anywhere so who knows on that one
there's actually another one right here
and on this one you can almost make out
the writing at the bottom wildsmith
maybe maybe this actually relates to
something we saw back in the menu titled
collections okay for this next one i
admit there's probably no way you missed
this one but how awesome is it that
we're gonna get peeves in this game
peeves confirmed you guys let's go
appears someone is trying to sneak
around in peeps is making things a
little more complicated for them here at
10 51 you can see a couple of violins
playing on their own which really helps
to make the world feel alive and well
magical where the magic just appears to
be working on its own and oh boy this
one right here i can't wait to see what
people think because this one to me
looks like an all too familiar icon for
fans of the series that's right to me it
looks awfully close to the mark of the
deathly hallows but with the wand
missing and instead in the middle it has
a question mark instead here we jump
inside the room of requirement and
you'll catch sight of a pot hopping on
one foot if you've read tales of beetle
the bard you may remember coming across
the story called the wizard and the
hopping pot author jk rowling described
the hopping pot tale as a moral story to
encourage wizards to use their magic for
good great shot right here where if you
look closely you can see what's clearly
a chocolate frog on the desk just behind
the menu also i have to say i love
whoever came up with the idea to include
the dung beetle statues here beside the
fertilizer area inside the room of
requirement you'll be able to create
your own menagerie where you can nurture
magical beasts and inside we catch a
brief glimpse of what i think is an
incredibly tiny owl shout out to pig
widgeon as well as this cat so pets
confirmed maybe even multiple pets
confirmed it would also seem this
trailer reveals that our character has
indeed witnessed and experienced death
as we can see the thestral flying by
here in hogsmeade we get a look at a
couple of different vendors and the menu
here confirms we'll be using currency
true to the books as you can make out
what appear to be galleons sickles and
canutes here at the top of the menu
looks like it will cost you a full
galleon to pick up a wigan weld potion
at 12 35 we get a quick shot of the
ollivander's branch located in hogsmeade
just behind the character here more
thestrals here at 1337 this time with
our character interacting directly with
them this next shot to me at least is
one of the most fascinating shots of the
whole trailer we see a goblin
chauffeuring our character and professor
fig through what i think has to be
gringotts if it's not gringotts it's
clearly some elaborate tunnel or cave
system that's been designed by the
goblins but again my money here is on
gringotts especially when you combine
this with the earlier shot where we were
looking through that portal because
through that portal i think 100 grand
gods on this next one i can't blame you
if you missed it because it happened
right after the evoda qadhafi revealed
trust me i completely missed it my first
time but you'll see a shot here inside
the hog's head which we know is in
hogsmeade and in this scene our
character is having a conversation with
this goblin shortly after that we see
these massive bones which have to be
that of a dragon right possibly a horned
serpent maybe even a basilisk avalanche
revealed a ton of hogwarts legacy
details in the state of play as well as
a playstation blog post i cover that
entire blog post here in the video on
the right side of your screen so check
that one out next as always people love
the internet thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon